Northern California's high-tech boom is
turning into a bust for many longtime
residents of San Francisco they say
housing costs are getting so high that
they're getting priced out of the city
they've called home for decades
a new survey says the bay area has three
of the top 5 most expensive cities in
the country for living comfortably
another study shows people who moved to
San Francisco between 2010 and 2016 made
almost $19,000 per year more than
existing residents John Blackstone has
more on the many people who worry about
the impact on the city's legendary charm
as the cost of living soars in San
Francisco Megan sweet plans to make a
few dollars with the garage sale before
moving out for good I've been in San
Francisco since the 70s and it's like it
was a wonderful place to be you know in
my 20s and 30s and 40s but now that I'm
in my 60s I mean I can't even afford a
cup of coffee anymore now that Rebecca
Werth and her husband have a new baby
they need a two-bedroom apartment but
they can't find one they can afford a
lot of my friends I move deeper into the
East Bay or to LA or Portland the fair
market rent for a two-bedroom apartment
in San Francisco was $3,100 a month the
median home price is 1.6 million dollars
in San Francisco a family of four with
an income of less than a hundred
seventeen thousand four hundred dollars
a year is considered low income by
federal housing authorities compare that
to Houston where low-income families
earned slightly less than sixty thousand
dollars
san Francisco's wealth largely built on
well-paid tech industry workers is
leaving virtually no part of the city
untouched by development all the old
shops are gone I mean it's like there
used to be a shoe repair place not there
anymore
the once gritty and affordable Mission
District is increasingly home to coffee
bars and trendy restaurants there's a
neighborhood that's changing and you it
is of course Charles belugas he's
founder and CEO of Suvla offering fine
food and wine but to keep costs down
there are no waiters you walk over here
you wonderfully
a little menu board right there diners
are expected to fill their own water
glasses because of this model we're able
to keep our prices the width the way
that we are we're able to keep the
product the way that it is even as all
the prices continue to go up around us
rising prices particularly for housing
are a major challenge facing London
greed elected mayor of San Francisco
just last month between 2010 and 2015
for every 8 jobs we created we created
one unit housing there has to be a
balance with the increasing number of
high paying tech jobs it can sometimes
seem like the sidewalks are paved with
gold
in fact golden manhole covers and other
street fixtures have recently been
spotted in the San Francisco Bay Area
the goldleaf applied by artist and
designer Eric Schmidt what does this
signify for me it's an artistic gestures
it came out of this observation again of
this the bay area becoming this sort of
like gilded community now it's so
expensive to live here that's only
attainable for the most wealthy for many
that means leaving their heart in San
Francisco but making their home
somewhere else
for CBS this morning I'm John Blackstone
it's not good for the city and there's
something deeply wrong with a housing
market if you could be making a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars and be Kings
that our logo and you can't be in the
place to other reasons it's such a
transient city that's right because
people can't stay for long